what does scott kelly experiencing right
now well i think he's in the first
quarter of his football game that's
going to last a year so he's very
excited everything's new he's readapting
to new crewmates and even though he's
been there before there's a bit of an
orientation factor since he was last
there so I think he's on a pretty good
high right now okay so he's on a high
but that high will neva get lower and
lower the longer the time you spend on
ISS so you know you spend a good several
months there yourself I mean what
happens Clayton when you pass the
six-month mark I mean what are we
actually trying to learn beyond let's
say six to eight months on the ISS well
the key here is that most people believe
we all want to go to Mars some day and
in order to do that the distance to
travel and the time that it's going to
take is long enough that a year in space
for scott kelly and mikhail kornienko
with us more information as to how the
human body can adapt and how it can
survive the you know we worry about I
issues we worry about hard issues we
worry about blood pressure issues the
longer these guys can stand space and
the more data we can gather the smarter
will become when we do decide to go two
more so what's the most unusual thing
that happens to you physically when you
come back after being there that long
well it kind of varies per person I
think but for most folks when you come
back from a long duration space like
you're very very heavy and you're very
very methodical and what you do simply
because you're pretty much exhausted and
your muscles haven't done what they do
on earth for a long time so it takes I
don't know for me it took about 24 hours
before I could actually walk stand and
behave what i thought was normally
although it was a three-week
rehabilitation process for me to be able
to run the same speed and amount that i
did before i left the planet or lip the
same amount wait wow um clean look there
is this fascination with going to Mars
you're puzzled by why we want to go well
I'm not necessarily puzzled by why we
want to go to Mars I'm puzzled by the
steps that we're taking to get there
believer that we should go to the moon
first and perhaps establish the lunar
base because if we really want to live
off the land on Mars like a lot of the
theorists tell us we can write like we
need to learn the techniques and learn
the design and the mechanisms of the
actual pieces of equipment that we're
going to need to do those things and to
do them three days away on Mar or on the
moon i think is a great way for us to
learn and to adapt our designs and to
overcome our deficiencies before we
enable ourselves to go on a six to
nine-month journey to the red planet I
think that's a great point so why aren't
we doing that why aren't we back on the
moon well I bet that's above my pay
grade apparently I think that we should
consider the lunar base as the first
step to going to Mars you know a lot of
people say well we've already done that
well we've visited the lunar surface but
we really didn't do a lot yeah you know
I would like to prove and have the
pieces of equipment that can get water
from the lunar surface or they can
create the oxygen or the hydrogen or
whatever it is we believe is there for
us to use I think we need to go there
and begin to develop the mechanisms that
are going to allow us to do that so
though and then apply that knowledge
tomorrow so Clayton um you know Elon
Musk over the weekend said that he
believes guys do we have that sound but
that he believes that we are going to go
to Mars in the next 10 years we will
have a mission to Mars in the next
decade is that is that possible well I
suppose with enough money invested
anything's possible I think we're a long
way from getting to Mars right now one
of the things people need to keep in
mind with scott kelly and those guys in
the station if you were going to ask me
to go to Mars I would want my spaceship
to be at least the size of three Space
Station modules in order to make that
journey now that's just clay talking but
most people think they see the designs
were these small capsules and things and
they believe that those might be the
things that go to Mars well they're
going to be attached to something bigger
I don't think we know what that is yet